this is a billion dollars we think and
that billion dollars belongs to r.j.
Rappaport and he's considered the king
of cash fake cash okay
king of fake cash my name is rich r.j.
Rappaport and I'm the president of RJR
props just a few years ago actually it
was nine years ago
oh sorry nine years ago RJ R props was
born it's a full-service prop house but
its specialty is cash think cash and
there's only a few people who can
legally make it and RJ is one of them we
work with 50 cent Kendrick Lamar Lil
Wayne Fat Joe Young Dolph and that's
just to name a few
RJ's prop money has been used in over
175 feature films television shows and
music videos and he devoted three full
years to perfecting that crisp green
paper we call money prop money
and we went down a long path and working
with the Secret Service and learning all
the laws to make sure that everyone that
uses it it will be legal for them and
it'll look fantastic but for those who
don't follow the rules they could wind
up in big trouble there was a rash of
arrests people were just literally
jailed because they were using prop
money that looked too real and I said to
myself I'm not gonna touch this unless I
know I'm doing it legally
alongside the Secret Service RG created
two different styles of prop money one
that is printed on both sides and is
perfect for that classic bank robbery
scene the other kind is so close to the
real deal it can only be printed on one
side otherwise it could end up in
circulation it's designed for the
classic money shot aka this the close-up
it's a tough business we all work hard
in it and prop money especially it's not
easy yeah sounds like it
thanks RJ for keeping fake money real
[Music]
these are sea turtle eggs and there are
two ways this situation can play out
there's either or there's so how can we
make sure this doesn't end up like this
well take a look again these aren't your
ordinary sea turtle eggs these eggs
could one day take down an entire
poaching network the story of these eggs
starts in Ann Arbor Michigan hi i'm kim
williams qian and i am a conservation
ecologist kim does research on a wide
variety of animals but we're here to
talk about endangered and threatened sea
turtles with sea turtles in central
america there's an issue of poaching of
the nests for consumption of the eggs
and so her team has developed a unique
solution to gather more information
about the poaching trade fake eggs with
GPS trackers we can hide these fake
turtle eggs in sea turtle nests our hope
is that these eggs will get poached
along with the others and transmit
information on their locations where is
it that they go after they're taken from
the beach but for this to work the fake
eggs have to be convincing they have to
have the right feel because sea turtle
eggs are kind of a little soft and
squishy they're not like chicken eggs
we've been using a 3d printer and a kind
of flexible plastic but they still don't
look quite right and this is when our
story moves to Los Angeles hello I'm
Lauren and Lauren works in Hollywood my
day-to-day job as I work on set as a
makeup artist which could be beauty
makeup prosthetics creature design wigs
blood so it made sense for Lauren to
help Kim make fake eggs we needed these
eggs to look realistic so feel realistic
and so that's kind of where I've come in
it was like the best way that I could
use my skills making prosthetics but to
actually like help a whole species of
turtles this is like it's a dream job
after months of revisions it's time to
put these eggs to the test in Costa Rica
hi again
you remember Kim she's here to deploy
the eggs herself on a protected
conservation area this is a place that's
very special because it's a very
important nesting site tonight a sea
turtle will come and I can test out
putting the false sea turtle eggs in the
nest not only will this project provide
Kim's team with valuable information on
poaching she and Lauren hope it will
inspire others as well wildlife poaching
can be abstract or too depressing to
even think about something about this
project kind of captures people's
attention here's this very simple unique
solution that I think then serves as a
jumping off point for people's
imaginations to learn more about this
trade all of us working on this project
are just doing it in our our weird
little nooks and wherever we can and it
just goes to show there's so many little
ways that everyone can help you don't
have to be making fake turtle eggs to
make a difference you can make a
difference in your own way
you
in movies like Carrie blood comes by her
buckets perfecting that red gooey mess
took a long time and several different
recipes this is the story of how fake
movie blood is made
[Music]
back before film and TV a simple red
handkerchief on stage symbolized blood
but it was kind of boring so some
theatres up the ante by boiling a bug
known for its red pigment they used the
Cochin you bug because it creates red
dye when black and white movies came
along pigment in a matter so Hollywood
simplified things by using chocolate
syrup then in the 1930s when
black-and-white movies turned to color
Hollywood needed a new blood trick enter
John Tyne Gate a retired pharmacist
living in England he concocted the most
realistic looking blood yet called
Kensington gore using a combination of
mostly golden syrup food coloring
cornflour and water the most famous of
the blood recipes though comes from a
man named dick Smith he came up with
something on par with a Julia Child
recipe the catch his recipe was
poisonous one ingredient Kodak photo
flow is deadly when consumed so people
started replacing the poison with
creamer and other items that won't kill
you today a lot of the fake blood you
see on screen is computer-generated
but if you want to be legit it should be
poison or bugs
you
in Japan restaurants and to be clear I
mean a ton of restaurants use plastic
food displays to entice customers and in
gujo province there's a small factory
that's responsible for more than half of
all the plastic sushi crab omelettes
duck ramen beef oh my god
that's all plastic this is satellite
Kabuki yahshua sizzle for condors did a
coconut kojocho nervous this Factory has
about 30 full-time artists because all
these plastic foods are made by hand
Kiko this thorn or dosa mo almost I
think in a monotonous in my must know
their iPod it is a burrito yuca saw him
oh no no Hong Kong really
he must know they a party ticket Eva
Marie Thomas
anandamaya ishigami Takahiro this
Takahiro is an artist here Nanoha tried
eno-san judoka named una habitación mas
para no so no ma no no Tim honest open
internal non-monetary Misano there now
an erection on a canary mistake serega
to you iman only hope win Katamari su
still not very much
this trend of plastic food in Japan has
been around since the 1930s but blew up
in the 50s and it is everywhere however
this food it doesn't come cheap cheese
hey Mon oldest además I'm back when
would I
this kid oh boy Okemah no kotoba a
kombucha Okemah no not kal-toh a
Hawaiian Jew my into you need enough is
madness it takes years of training to
master this art sight a demonise on a no
ratio and I thought mo nods couldn't I
una moto Dimas quick example a bowl of
ramen might take three hours to make
while a fish many many more but our most
general mosquito no sorry no suki
ricotta Turkish or aluminum ET Mostow
Keiko a party though he who needs good
Tyra he no courtesy you dare to talk
online Mossad a a body so even on Emilio
cou this name you can
homo knowledge cascaded couple you go
today you know the Hong Kong lightly
[Music]
Paris without people know this isn't an
apocalypse this is Paris in China
Tian Yu Chang is a luxury real estate
development and a paris look-alike
located in Hangzhou China as China
became the world's fastest-growing
economy real estate developments popped
up all over the country some modelled
from famous western cities this Chinese
Paris started construction in 2007 and
while the city is built to hold 10,000
people only 2,000 live there full-time
making it feel more like a ghost town
the lack of people could be linked to
where Tian Yu Chang is located
surrounded by miles and miles of
farmland the eiffel tower replica is
about one-third the size of the original
and stands surrounded by copycat French
architecture
[Music]
and just like the original it's a great
backdrop for newlyweds looking for an
everlasting memory you know what they
say imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery
[Music]